all right let's do some audience
questions really good ones this week
first one is from Ilya who asked what
foods are overrated
I've got a couple thoughts on this one
is like trend foods that become very
popular but then there's also just like
food concepts that I think are overrated
so first of all any food that like has
gold on it like gold leaf I find to be
absolutely insane and some people may
not have heard of this but I've seen a
lot of food deck documentaries there are
desserts like chocolate desserts where
there will be like this gold flake added
on top to make it extra look jewelry a
sword a kid in tow I just find it to be
absolute in total idiocy that's number
one
you're not talking about like mac and
cheese or something when they'll Vita
propose this idea that you got to taste
the gold right not exactly no not
exactly that I mean actual like gold
flake like what you would see in
Goldschlager not that Pat would know
anything about that of course but but
like as a food concept that pink is
overrated super foods the concept of a
super food right and you see like acai
berries or blueberries or a superfood
avocados a superfood people are trying
to communicate that the food has some
like particularly amazing benefits
different foods have different
nutritional properties no one food is
going to provide you everything that you
need in terms of nutrients indefinitely
and I think that the concept of a
superfood anything that's called a
superfood I find to be a food that's
overrated yeah I mean my thoughts go
towards these trends that have come out
of like the yuppie earthy crunchy
community which are foods like kale and
avocados and quinoa and I would say they
are overwrite it overrated but then
again when you put all those things
together and some sort of salad I mean
that sounds delicious to me it's a vegan
paradise really I mean it sort of is
yeah no III mean keen wise it wise
quinoa so popular right I mean if you in
the end it's it's not that different or
kale even what's how's it different I
love to Haile but there's many like how
is kales that different from collard
greens or Swiss chard or whatever we're
talking about similar foods here it just
becomes super super trendy I also this
is it this has become a thing avocado
toast have you read about the whole like
yuppie avocado toast it's a new way to
attack Millennials but maybe we all
enjoy avocado toast yeah and it's like
yeah I Mikado toast is fine paying $18
for it at some hipster bar seems kind of
silly but if you get an avocado and you
get some bread and you spread the
avocado on the bread like it's just it's
one of many things you could put on
Brett I don't know why is it so crazy
how about ice cream ice cream seems
pretty overrated to me I mean there's
entire stores dedicated to just serving
you ice cream okay and I'm put the vegan
thing aside it's just it's a messy
dessert option huh there's really not
much to it I just think it's an
overrated food I don't agree with this
criticism no but no I think that ice
cream is great it just seems as if taste
can be such a subjective thing it can't
be black canary prints of a penny the
thing about ice cream is even as an
adult the possibility or plan to get ice
cream is just as exciting to me now as
it was as a kid like that candy tells me
something that ice cream ice cream is
legit but you're not as excited when it
comes to you know going to a coffee shop
to get coffee and you'd prefer to make
that at your own house yeah that's true
I think that only proves my point though
oh maybe yeah all right but thank you I
appreciate that
any fast food promo like the McRib is
here I've got to go get a McRib which I
don't even I think it's some kind of
like reconstituted pork like thing that
McDonald's has come in and out I've
never had a McRib I I don't get it I
think it's a totally bogus thing or KFC
had that atrocity of a sandwich that you
replaced the bread with chicken-fried
chicken and they put cheese and bacon in
between it I mean who would eat that I
didn't see that I saw one that it was
waffles replaced the bread and then I'd
chicken between that don't don't eat
that that I can agree with yeah okay so
anyway lots of foods are trends that are
annoying is a food overrated
I don't know depends exactly what you
mean but good question Ilya